hey this is presh to Walker let X and Y
be real numbers such that
56x plus 33y is equal to negative y
divided by x squared plus y squared and
33x minus 56y is equal to x divided by x
squared plus y squared
what is the value of the absolute value
of x plus the absolute value of y
I think adarsh for the suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
for a complex problem like this the
trick is to use complex numbers let Z be
equal to X plus I multiplied by y
we will multiply the first equation by I
let's distribute through
now we will add the second equation to
the first equation
we'll simplify this in a minute so we
have 33x plus 56 IX plus 33 iy minus 56y
is equal to x minus iy all over x
squared plus y squared
now let's simplify the right hand side
now let's suppose we're taking a complex
number X Plus i y multiplied by its
conjugate x minus i y
if we work out this binomial the i x y
terms will cancel out so we get x
squared plus y squared
so from here let's imagine we have these
terms in the denominator and we have x
minus iy in the numerator
so the x minus i y terms will cancel out
so x minus iy divided by x squared plus
y squared is equal to 1 divided by X
Plus i y and that is exactly equal to Z
so this is equal to 1 over Z so the
fraction on the right hand side
simplifies to be 1 over Z
and now we can do some further
simplification on the left hand side
from the first two terms Factor an X and
from the next two terms factor a y
then further Factor an i
so now how can we simplify this we can
factor out 33 plus 56i and that will be
multiplied by X Plus i y but X Plus i y
is equal to Z
now we can cross multiply so we get Z
squared is equal to 1 divided by 33 Plus
56i
so let's imagine we want 33 plus 56i to
be the square of some complex number A
Plus bi if we expand the binomial and
then we match up coefficients we're
going to need a squared minus B squared
to be equal to 33 and 2ab to be equal to
56. that means a b will be equal to 28.
so we can look at factors of 28 and we
might get lucky in this case we do we
have 7 times 4 is equal to 28 and 7
squared minus 4 squared is equal to 33.
so we have a is equal to 7 and B is
equal to 4.
so 1 divided by 33 plus 56i is equal to
1 divided by the square of 7 plus 4i
since Z squared is equal to this we must
have Z is equal to plus or minus 1
divided by 7 plus 4i we now multiply the
numerator and the denominator by the
conjugate so this will simplify to be
plus or minus 7 minus 4i all over 7
squared plus 4 squared and this is equal
to plus or minus 7 minus 4i over 65
therefore we have two possibilities X Y
can either be 7 over 65 and negative 4
over 65 or the pair can be negative 7
over 65 and 4 over 65.
but from here we want to evaluate the
absolute value of x plus the absolute
value of y so that'll be 7 over 65 plus
4 over 65 which is equal to 11 over 65
and that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time
foreign
[Music]